foie gras de Normandie vin du langue
d'un croussillon ou encore escargot des
Yvelines les produits du terroir étaient
à l'honneur ce weekend au manège royal
de Saint-Germain en laai pour sa 21e
édition le Salon du vin et de la
gastronomie accueillait une quarantaine
d'exposants l'objectif donner l'eau à la
bouche aux visiteurs pour faire
découvrir les produits des différentes
régions françaises très très bon
producteur avec un échantillon un peu de
toutes les régions ils peuvent parler de
leur
métier peuvent vraiment transmettre leur
passion sur les produits qu'ils font
apprécier des produits authentiques et
traditionnels escargot au beurre
persiller feuilleté en passant par des
croquilles cet élevage yvelinois
d'escargot proche de mant la jolie
démontré son savoir-faire une production
locale de l'élevage jusqu'à la vente moi
je n'élève que du gros gris c'est
l'escargot vraiment que l'on trouve
qu'en élevage et et qui s'élève en 6
mois de temps il est élevé en France
donc ça c'est déjà quelque chose qui est
important et puis après tout est fait
donc sur place l'élevage la cuisine et
après on vend à la maison on a un
magasin et puis après on fait quelques
salons pour faire connaître justement
les produits parmi les producteurs
ivelinois il y a aussi h au miel
installé depuis 5 ans au m nul dans la
Haute Vallée de Chevreuse l'entreprise
produit près de 500 kg de miel par an
bah c'est vraiment un miel local un miel
local qui est brut de ruche c'està-dire
qu'on on on on le récolte tel que avec
un chatignier très parfumé excellent
pour les pour les pour les gâteaux les
pains d'épices et surtout un miel blanc
de
printemps fruitier et cerisier près de
2000 curieux ont répondu présent cette
année au salon du vin et de la
gastronomie prochaine édition en mars